if you take many things for granted they
are difficult to explain and you have to
be asked the question by someone like
your Rob why European why democracy but
if they are in danger suddenly then you
think very hard it's a variation of the
American if it ain't broke don't fix it
but if it is broke you have to fix it
then to fix it you have to think about
it so I was thinking that if we I wanted
to begin from today my contribution to
this coffeehouse discussion think for a
moment about Ukraine think about the
energy that was suddenly created in the
Ukraine what was it about a year and a
half ago two years ago when the trouble
started where there were demonstrations
that turned violent and turned into this
terrible war Civil War and non civil as
well with Russia it started with people
who wanted passionately to belong to
Europe that should be something to cause
honest that should be something to go
against the apathy and the inertia of I
Europe has many problems so why bother
with it or let's see what's wrong with
it rather than what's good in it and
think that people were protesting with
passion and then started dying for it
and if people are dying for something
and they are not mere opportunists or
people people looking after material
gain there must be something in that
idea in that idea that deserves at least
our attention I think Rob you said that
the grease grease is about to probably
will go out of the European Union you
the UK is in the process possibly of
going out to the European Union well
both both those statements I contest
Greece may go out of the European Union
but there are very many Greeks who are
against that option and are willing to
work for this not to happen and Mr
Cameron wants to have a referendum and I
don't know why not I'm not British but I
think the outcome if that is not at all
certain that it will be that we go out
so rather than say why I would be
feed like a European under normal
circumstances like SE 5-10 years ago if
I was speaking to you I would refer to
the culture and the values and the old
civilization the new civilization and my
culture which is a combination of Greek
culture an old language and a modern
Western education and stay on the
present situation where to me the battle
for Europe is for you it is being fought
for Europeans I mean well-intentioned
Europeans even the best friends of
Greece it is being fought regarding
greece in the in Brussels in Germany in
Berlin in London in Paris in Athens
between Greek and politicians from Greek
politicians and politicians from other
European countries to me the battle for
Europe at this moment is being fought
inside Greece by those of us like myself
who accept a strong part or the biggest
part of the create the blame both for
the crisis which was led us to the into
the program for aid five years ago we
accept the possibility the
responsibility both for what happened in
those years that led us to the crisis
for our parcel ability and parcel
inability to try and solve the problem
with the European Union for five years
and then who accept fully the
responsibility now and think that our
present government is going the wrong
way trying to solve this problem because
I think that one of the core values of a
Western let's say enlightenment type
culture is self-criticism and rational
analysis so I think by those tools we
see the great responsibilities of Greece
also and we feel that fighting inside
Greece the populace tendency that is
essentially anti-european I hear the
argument again and again and again in
Greece that Europe is not democratic to
those who say Europe is not democratic I
go and live in a country which is really
not democratic and then come back and
tell me that Europe is not democratic I
will accept that Europe is not
democratic only if I accept that
democracy does not exist anywhere in the
world but democracy is not a culture or
an institution of extremes it is a
culture of collaboration and
collaboration has to do with making many
mistakes and living with them it is a
tragic in the ancient sense polity and
not an ideal not a false utopia so those
of us who are fighting for the ideal of
Europe at the moment in Greece against
ourselves against our worst part as I
think which is essentially under
European and I think a big part of that
is in government at the moment expressed
in anti-european essentially populist
rhetoric are really feeling that we are
European we want to be European we are
fighting to be European in defence of
Western liberal democracy
you